We started with the simple
equation of a line, y = mx + b.
Where m is the coefficient of
the variable and b is the y-intercept.
If you have more data that you
believe has a linear relationship
you can expand the equation to y =
b0 + b1x1 + b2x2 + b3x3 and so on.
In this equation y is
still the target variable.
B0 is the intercept or
the baseline value, b1, b2,
b3, represent the coefficients of
the variables x1, x2, x3 and so on.
A Linear Regression will find values for
b0, b1, b2, b3.
And these values represent
the relationship we observe between
the predictor variables and
the target variable.
This model is referred to as Linear as
the expression is based on a linear
combination.
An expression constructed
from a set of terms
by multiplying each term by a constant
and then adding the results.
With this data set,
our equation would look like this,
y = b0 + b1x1 + b2x2.
Using Microsoft Excel or Google Sheets,
we can calculate the values of the
coefficients and check the correlation
coefficients to see if our Multiple
Linear model is a better predictor.